this is a production of Cornell
University
hi good afternoon everybody kind of I'm
very happy under very excited to be here
back in Ithaca so because I did my PhD
here and I will show you my favorite
photo in Ithaca so I work with this
young guy okay so and after I returned
to Taiwan in the past 14 years I have
been doing research on Oh kids so title
I work on the physiology study of okay
so for example a floral floral
immigration or post-harvest tissue
culture and a lot in mera nutrition so
today I want to share with you kind of
the some interesting result I think with
you regarding that infant in offices and
the with focus on nitrogen so I think
many of the many of you here should have
known that right now
Phalaenopsis is the number one photo
crop worldwide so it's the number one in
the United States and is the number one
kind of being kind of most of the other
country so here I'm offering you some of
the background information why I
conducted those study so if you check
the literature you will found a lot of
in concern result we got in the
Phalaenopsis on nutrition so sometimes
they are even control over see to each
other even they are using the same code
for some time they are using the same
measure they may feel very very
differently so why and the many of the
core they try to reduce or terminate the
nitrogen fertilization given the forcing
period of phalaenopsis so is this a good
practice I don't think so so I have some
research on that so under then kind of
course as a researcher we have to
provide some recommendation to the core
because right now the Fed analysis is a
very very important crop a worldwide so
the story started about 13 years ago we
conducted an experiment at least we had
kind of different rate of nitrogen
infrared of phosphorus and a different
way of potassium and we kind of do the
treatment or to the fair analysis but
even with kind of nitrogen deficiency
for more than 18 years so it was one
year and a half the fattiness novices
can still flower was to spike and the
signal for the phosphorus deficiency
under the potassium deficiency so they
are very very strong so kind of here I
want to know why they are so good tied
up to deal with the kind of the nutrient
stress stress even with such a long time
so we thought there is a kind of very
very strong kind of nutrient storage
pool in fear analysis so they are very
very tolerant to the nutrient or stress
so then we try to induce the
deficiencies Sifton unfair analysis but
we have to use a small depression
because we thought with a smaller plan
they have a smaller size of the nutrient
storage pool under then we have to wait
for about eight months even with a
smaller plan to get a differentiation of
the nitrogen deficiency so this is some
chlorosis and the phosphorus deficiency
so us it'll reduce our growth under some
proposed pigmentation underneath under
the phosphorus deficiency under you will
find some or necrosis symptom under the
potassium deficiency so those kind of
six simple turn of the deficiency
is very similar to that in other crop
but they are also something different
with fair analysis for example a took a
long time to have the deficiency
symptoms and it is very difficult or to
induce under then are something
different for example for the deficiency
of potassium we can observe that on the
upper lip in the literature most of the
deficits of channel potassium will
appear in the lower lip so also some
similarity also some are differences so
the part one of my talk I want to show
you how good they are still in and they
utilize the nutrient are with
Phalaenopsis and this is another my
favorite photo so i want to show you
they are very very tolerant to many kind
of environmental stress so they can dip
in at age that the bird do not like okay
so from the trait of the some of the
data I just show you we think kind of
there should be a very very large pore
of the stone nitrogen in fed analysis we
think this is a reason that different
researcher got different experimental
result so another thing is that the
friend abscess they respond very very
slowly to the application of fertilizer
so this is also make it very difficult
to understand its nutrient requirement
so for my study I want to distinguish
the stone nitrogen and the fertilizer
nitrogen because in apprenticea
Phalaenopsis this already so many
nitrogen has been stolen at issue for
example in in amino acid in protein in
nucleic acid they are not of natural
trait so if we just put on fertilizer to
different treatment and we do the
analysis maybe we were just kind of a
debtor nitrogen table is already in the
print issue so here I use the stable
isotope
nitrogen 15 to distinguish the nitrogen
has been stored in the print issue so
this is the stone nitrogen you can just
think that way this is the stone
nitrogen before we started the
experiment and also the effect of
fertilizer nitrogen so I miss the
fertilizer effect
I avoid apply after the treatment so
nitrogen 15 is a stable isotope and it
has a one more Neutron than that of a
natural June 14
so just use the mass we will be able to
distinguish nitrogen 15 and the nitrogen
14 so by this way I will be able to kind
of compare the stone nitrogen under the
fertilizer on nitrogen so I use the
enrichment method of the nitrogen 15
labeling so I just applied a label
fertilizer into the substrate and after
a certain period of time I will check
the concentration in different organ of
the fair announcers so for each harvest
I would had dry way and I will get a
nitrogen concentration after analysis so
by multiple them I will get I will have
a nitrogen content under by multiple a
driving driveway under nitrogen 15
concentration I will get a nitrogen 15
contact but there are some natural
abundance of nitrogen 15 are in the
nature so we have to subtract them so
and after we do that then we will get
nitrogen 15 concentration at present
access and also the nitrogen content
access so when you say the earth access
in the kind of following or data you
will know last result from the
fertilizer treatment so kind of we had
deducted the natural abandon or nitrogen
15 so this is the first our isotope our
study we will apply the label fertilizer
and
in the 8 day period we analyzed the
nitrogen 15 concentration in the first
leaf and in the fourth deal so here are
kind of because the first leaf were
still growing so you will see the dry
weight our was increasing during the at
P at a period but now you can see that
the nitrogen content was also increased
because look biomass is increasing so
are you substrate or this one by this
one then you all know that the first
leap acquire four point three mini gram
of nitrogen so remember this 4 points
free mini crammed under kind of by the
analysis of nitrogen 15 are you a see
here first the first leaf is a stronger
thing or sink or than that of the
firstly yeah because they are growing
under during these eight days kind of
the first leap got 170 microplane of
nitrogen 15
nitrogen 15 Kaido we just have 24 2
percent of the nitrogen 15 in the
fertilizer so pilot calculation we know
are during this day period the first
leap got only point 5 mini gram of
nitrogen fertilizer nitrogen from the
fertilizer in previous slide I say four
point three so it means that the first
third leaf only got a percent of the
nitrogen Baker from the fertilizer so
how about other eighty-eight percent of
the nitrogen yeah because they are from
our somewhere else
I mean last from the stove on nitrogen
so then I did another kind of Kenko
study so we are check the nitrogen 15 at
a different time from the vegetative
growth or
to the or reproductives gross and here
you can see it again this is the our
Unicron live and the digital good so
during a vegetative or gross at least
two organ were strong sync for nitrogen
but after the Fed analysis has the spike
the nitrogen 15 concentration are in a
good decrease under that further
decrease when the inflorescence was
developing so it means that dude came at
as a storage organ for the nitrogen and
the provided nitrogen for the further
development of the info racers and we
got similar result by checking the
nitrogen 15 content the nitrogen 50
content in a maturity decrease are when
the essence was developing so then we
further our conduct another research to
check kind of the storage function of
the mature live so because this is
different from what we saw in the
literature so we have to prove that so
we put a label fertilizer arm under then
we that we did it kind of last for at
week so during this at week the nitrogen
15 will just be partitioned to many of
the kind of old organ so then we do the
root excision so this is no this has
been doing both or 25 percent or 75 50
percent and 75 percent of a tooth has
been excised so we want to know so what
would happen if we move they move or
some of the dirt so here are for the
nitrogen 15 content or you will see that
with the mode dude has been removed the
nitrogen 15 content in the dirt decrease
so it's obvious because we remove the
dirt
then we remove
nitrogen ar-15 from the dirt and the
frontier the nunik relief the treatment
you will see that kind of the nitrogen
content is quite stable so no difference
between the treatment and the is the
same for the info racers because they
are strong sync so the friend apps just
do their best to provide the nitrogen or
to the new Negro on unique are going
organ so what is very very interesting
that surprised is that the decrease of
the nitrogen 15 content in the maturity
so you kind of prune the root and the
you got a result of the reduce natural
u15 content in the mature leaf
it means that the mature lip also has a
function of natural tree storage and the
lay can provide nitrogen to the newly
grown leaf or to the inflorescence
during the reproductive stage so this is
very interesting that maturely if in
fear analysis also act as nitrogen
storage oden not can provide nitrogen
are kind of to the infrared sense or
Department okay and the kind of we know
that a for the infrareds development
some of nitrogen came from the stone
nitrogen and here I want to know so for
a nitrogen here are well that just come
to come from this stage or this stage of
every stage so this is a very very small
size prime this is the medium size this
is large size so each stage took about
four to five months so each stage so for
the first experiment is under imperfect
relation kind of I compare these three
stage
and then for the second experiment I can
I compare just a large size print stage
and the force in our period because the
fair enough see the growth so slow just
for this one single experiment it took
me two years to complete
yeah so I have to separate these two
experiment under then I also have
another experiment that I did that under
import validation and under reduce our
fertilization so kind of three our
experiment so here are we keep our
nitrogen 15 level fertilizer two
different stage under then after a six
week of treatment
we're apart it to remove the nitrogen 15
that we kept our to the fan analysis and
here we have the negative control no
nitrogen 15 and here is the positive
control we apply not what you think in
two older three stages of the growth
just just as a positive control and I
have to emphasize that all the nitrogen
label applied to all the treatment they
were all the same kind of different
between the treatment is just the timing
of the nitrogen 15 laboring so and here
are when the crane was flowering so it
took a long time so from the the young
priests age are truly spot visible stage
is more than one years so it's about
kind of 16 months or or fourteen months
then in the info racers we found the
nitrogen v came from the small size
print the medium size print and the
large size print so it means that
because of the small size is just listed
and the father a kind of the large size
is like this big so it's a huge
difference but even are a very very
young or very nasty sprain make a stone
nitrogen and provided nitrogen for
infrared system even one year
so they have a strong very strong
capacity are to stoke the nutrient even
a very very young so this is kind of a
total nitrogen are contained in a small
sized friend a medium-sized friend and a
large sized friend and because in a
large size printer Hobart more biomass
of course the total nitrogen our
companies hire but they was once a very
very interested no matter how much
nitrogen they have accumulated during
that single stage there was about a
certain percent of nitrogen has been
stored and the youth are to provide the
informations so it's kind of a
percentage of 6% to 8% so it's a very
very special kind of terroristic for our
fair analysis so kind of the finding for
this experiment is that they can store
the nitrogen very well and provide on
the nitrogen later for the infra
resonsible development even or one year
later and if we kind of calculate the
relative concentrate our concern
contribution are to the inferences on
nitrogen is kind of you'll get this
number
16:25 under ninety five or fifteen nine
percent for our different or stage under
then I had a kind of experiment B so I
just compare kind of the large size or
price stage are during a vegetative
stage under then I apply that during the
reproductive stage again I want to say
the game that all the treatment received
the same among of total nitrogen so here
you will see if we apply the nitrogen 15
during the vegetative stage the newly
grown deep will have the most are kind
of higher nitrogen 15 concentration
because they are strong sync during this
stage but if we repair
naturally 15 during a repetitive stage
the the info races will have a kind of
high amount of nitrogen 15 content among
the open so this is kind of a strong
sync during the reproductive stage so if
we were partner this is nitrogen 15
content it will apply the nitrogen 15 15
during the vegetative stage or they will
stow it and the later on uo5 17 9 micro
gram of nitrogen 15 in the info racers
and if you are applied on nitrogen 15
during the reproductive stage it will
end up in the inference 174 microgram
then we can do kind of the relative
contribution for this to stage so follow
in for kind of the relative contribution
is 31 percent from the last precise
stage and the 69 percent are from the
fertilizer we just applied to
Phalaenopsis during the office in our
period so yeah so ah because um for the
nitrogen fertilizer we applied during
the forcing period is accounted for 69
percent of the nitrogen or in the info
racers so it's very important to
continue supreme nitrogen even during
the forcing or period so we had the
experiment a or we got a ratio of
contribution we have aspera B so then we
can calculate kind of the relative
contribution because laid both
experiment has the same stage of the
large size pram so for the nitrogen are
in the inflorescence 7 7% from the small
size stage 11 from the medium-sized are
25% from the large size or price stage
under 57 percent of the nitrogen in
brief in fluorescence came from the
fertilizer we just apply or during the
foursome period
so it's bare
very important to give them sufficient
on nitrogen
even during the forcing or period then
for the next experiment is kind of
everybody are complicated so we have
kinda we try to reduce the fertilizer
level during the forcing period and to
see how they utilize the stove a
nutrient are if they in conquer the
nutrient are stress so this is the floor
fertilization we label is at different
time vegetative stage reproductive stage
and the further reduce our strengths of
the fertilizer in the same hour to labor
to kind of to time kind of twist age of
the nitrogen laboring under for this one
we didn't give any or nitrogen on - fair
enough stood in the faucet or period so
then we cut with cheddar or nitrogen 15
concentration in the info racers so I
will read this off graph like this way
so this is a important relation this is
reduce fertilization and when we reduce
the fertilization during the forcing
period you will get more nitrogen 15 in
the info racers so it means if when they
encounter a nutrient stress they were
used more the nitrogen has been stalled
or in the open tissue so I would do a
kind of I will show you kind of the
credible data for comparing the two
stage so the same calculation so under
imperfect relation kind of the large
size print stage or the nitrogen achieve
accounted for 43% under the nitrogen
fertilizer are 57% and the name when we
are reduce the fertilization
during the foursome period the ratio
change yeah
so the stone nitrogen accounted for 89%
under the fertilizer nitrogen just
accounted for 11 percent because we
reduce the supply of fertilizer during
the foursome period and of course if we
didn't give the Phalaenopsis any
fertilizer of course 100 percent of the
nitrogen are in the info racers came
from the stove nitrogen so they will be
able to store the nitrogen and they use
it for info residence development later
so here I'm showing you the kind of
effect of the reduce of fertilization or
during the forcing period so if you got
a very very healthy fair enough to start
with then the effect of the fertilizer
nitrogen during the forcing period was
minor because it's just a difference of
two flower they can still perform well
on flowering of the kind of on Friday
so the finding here is that stone
nitrogen becomes a very very important
natural resource for the info residents
development when the fertility label is
limited so for the second part I would
like to kind of show you some
information very very brute briefly for
the progressive change of the nitrogen
of the carbon our queen the Phalaenopsis
are developing I mean for oldest kind of
organ order stage and I want to note the
effect of nitrogen fertilizer on the
flowering of freedom novices because
many of the grow they think they can
kind of change the flooring of
Phalaenopsis by man meaning pet the or
fertilization or during the forcing or
period so then we check kind of the
carbon and the nitrogen label at a
different stage
then we will get the ricean ratio and I
have to research on this kind of
strength - analysis for such a long time
I have none the result but here at one
more coffee bar is a miniature time so
for a miniature is something that just
very very compact and the for the same
time type is kind of huge is huge so I
want to know kind of the trend of the CN
ratio changes so here's three so uh you
will see some newer system data here but
for me it's Blair kind of for a carbon
concentration they are relative stable
so they just kind of a range from our
forty one percent two forty three
percent for me is quite a stable but you
are fired
decreasing trend on nitrogen on nitrogen
so when they was young when they were
just differ asked high nitrogen about
four four percent but when they get
mature and they were able to flower you
just drop to about two percent so you
will find a kind of discrete at the
decreasing trend when they get mature
become more mature and because this is
stable this is decreasing so for the CN
ratio you'll find an increase a strand a
trend esta prang are getting more mature
so then we want to know if we change the
nitrogen label or during the forcing
period will not affect the performance
the floating performance of do these two
cultivar so ah this is the standard type
this is the miniature so of course here
for the nitrogen concentration when we
reduce the fertilizer nitrogen that will
reduce the our nitrogen concentration in
the tissue so it is quite significant
and the list means that the Sein ratio
will increase as the fertilizer nitrogen
decrease because the carbon our label is
quite our stable then how about a
flowering so here for the center type
Phalaenopsis the trench are in the
fertilizer nitrogen did affect taste to
spiking but if you look at the number
whistler control it's just about two day
difference so practically i would
consider kind of no inference about for
the miniature type you will see some
impact so if you increase the or
nitrogen neighbor during the forcing
period that would delay the spiking for
about nine days so kind of the
fertilizer nitrogen manipulation has
more impact under miniature type
Phalaenopsis and for me is kind of is
quite simple because our pages has a
kind of smaller on nitrogen or poor so
yeah this is just to show you kind of
the deficiency of nitrogen were at the
basic fraud flooring for about or two
days so it's not a big deal and the
photometer type with high rate of
nitrogen that made in later flowering
for about nine day ten days so kind of
kind of fertilizer nitrogen has more
impact on miniatures - analysis than the
standard type or fair analysis so here I
think I'd of the prony number is very
very important so even we change it a
fertilizer rate or during the forcing
period for the standard - analysis the
Froude number was not affected but
changing the fertilizer nitrogen will
affect the froning number in the
miniature Phalaenopsis
again just because they have less kind
of a smaller pool of nitrogen stone
nitrogen so but kind of they were some
effect but with the lower rate of
nitrogen will decrease the number of the
flower so I don't reckon
the clora to reduce the nitrogen during
the kind of the 14-hour period so I will
just show you the photo the nitrogen
rate you're enforcing did not affect the
standard type of Phalaenopsis much but
the world rate of the nitrogen order
enforcing will reduce the are throw
number of Fred in offices
so this is the kind of the our
conclusion for the previous two
experiment so not too much effect under
standard type Phalaenopsis some effect
on the miniature type so the rate of the
unnatural unity reinforcing work at the
basic of roaring and the high rate would
delay the frauding of the minions would
have Phalaenopsis but kind of the
falling quality the best foreign quality
still come from the regular our nitrogen
fertilization so we don't need to reduce
all terminate the nitrogen application
ordering or forcing and this is just
because they have different size of
stone nitrogen and this also is brand
kind of the inconsistent result has been
existed exist in the literature so under
then kind of further less part i want to
kind of demonstrate the optima medium ec
are for the Phalaenopsis or cultivation
so because from my previous experiment
we knew that we have to keep fed an
abscess continuous fertilization even
from a very very young trend throughout
our tutor are forcing or period so here
we did we kept different grade of
fertilizer to Phalaenopsis and the with
higher rate of fertilization you will
have kind of higher or shoot or try way
but that would decrease
the truth booth biomass so we think it's
very important to keep the good bearers
of the chute to rule ratio and we have
that are for the treatment at 100
pathway medium nitrogen of the
fertilizer so they have a good growth
here annaleigh also have a good
flowering quality and for this the
medium you see was ranged from point six
to one point zero this is semen per
meter under then we want to know the
route quality the relationship between
the good quality under the medium you
see by this way we can also determine
the optimum or medium EC so we did it
experiment in 10 nursery are in Taiwan
so we found that to have a good good
quality the median EC must below are
point nine something like that so then
we are concluded that the fertilizer
grade at 100 pata Miam nitrogen was
about right under the medium ec r can be
target at one point zero if we are doing
that by pull through so I gave this
recommendation to the grower so the
target ec r is one point zero this is
Simon per meter if they are doing that I
pull through and the kind of another
girl I like to use a facility like this
so if if they are using a delta t WT
sensor the target EC is one point one
kind of we do the regression between the
eight how we obtain from this our
facility under that from post room so
then after this then we kind of tested
this idea a more than seven salah/prayer
seven zero zero zero pen so kind of we
got good result and very very confident
about this recommendation or to the are
fair
of course so then here comes to my
conclusion that this is the deficiency
cistern for nitrogen for phosphorus
under for potassium so it's kind of a
little bit similar with other crop but
they are something different they are
they have a very very good capacity or
two stone nitrogen under sometime the
symptoms are different because it
nitrogen unknown is the symptom of the
atashi 'm deficiency appear under belief
so can the deficiency was very very
severe and the further sink on the sauce
relationship for nitrogen on the newly
grown organ is the major sink during the
vegetative growth under the info
resonance is the major or natural gene
think our orinda or reproductive stage
under what organ acts as the nitrogen
source is the mature live under the root
so and the kind of they are very very
good on kind of student nutrient
understood nitrogen so even a very very
young plant they can store the nitrogen
for more than one year and they useful
that the development of the Phalaenopsis
so on the because the fertilizer
nitrogen applied during the for superior
accountable the 57 percent of the
nitrogen in info racers so it's very
very important to keep get given the
fair analysis attempt read on nitrogen
or fertilizer under although we can
change the CN ratio by the reduction of
nitrogen during the forcing period but
that has a kind of little effect on the
flowering of the fair analysis if they
have already stole a lot of money
Trojans so maybe by doing this the
quantity of the fed NRC will be
sacrified so
I don't recommend to reduce the nitrogen
during the fourth in our period so
because they are epified underlay cannot
tolerate too high salt but we have to
give them a continuous supply of
nitrogen so I will recommend Agora to
test the medium easy under it could be
targeted at 1.0 by paw through and the
1.1 by the delta t weg sensor so this is
what I want to share with you and I I
thank very much for the invitation to be
here to kind of see de Ithaca kind of
see the campus again and I think my
students all conducted the experiment
and I also thank the financial support
from Taiwan government so nice oh my
talk and I thank you for your attention
and I would like to have your comment or
take any of you a question thank you
[Applause]
okay niebo are there any questions from
Geneva the best crowd here has no
questions
thank you the first place look at
concentrations lower than one yes yes in
different kind of a stoppie
so not in this one okay yeah so we check
something like 50 25 but because kind of
is kind of another experiment so I
didn't brought up here you know you
differentiate it for like fertilizer
nitrogen from store store not yes like
you know when you grow the plant
any medium mm-hmm yes kind of I kind of
yes yeah sometime we cannot do all that
influence from the substrate I here
because we are compared in that kind of
both treatment they were in all our
second most but we do the laboring a
different time is some kinda odd effect
of the specular most yeah if we just
kind of of course for the kind of kind
of the deficiency of nitrogen is
difficult because it will take even
longer because layers some on nitrogen
in a substrate but for kind of the older
nitrogen 15 study is okay because they
both have the same substrate yeah so we
have to think about the nitrogen that
that was provided by the speaker no more
so very good point okay so yes that's
also a very good question okay so Kaito
the gentleman asked kind of the nitrogen
form will have some effect on the kind
of course of the Friday of fair analysis
under within the research and the kind
of the best kind of racial the nitrogen
form is kind of the nitrous should be
high so something like morning are 75%
so fair enough scroll quite well our
with high nitrate so
75% nitrate all 100% natural they just
don't like that much of ammonia and the
the other says is when we are talking
about on nitrogen form we have to
consider the pH but if you go to a fair
analysis you will always find a very
very low pH using a second most as a
substrate the ph t''i the ph could be as
though as 2.8 2.9 it's very very
difficult for us to image ah it's a
reality so but actually for from my
study the the fertilizer will make the
pH low and the most important factor is
the dude of Phalaenopsis the dutiful
alphadon abscess will make the substrate
more acid under tongue to the pH of 3
they just like some acid environment I
think it's because fairness is the up
fire they just do their best to acquire
nutrient so they they made reduce
something acid to exchange for the
nutrient so that's what I know about a
nitrogen form
thank you I do use the terms auto fire
to your immobilization for the nitrogen
that store no I didn't check that yeah
yes oh tissue culture and when I was
doing research I was very very picky for
the you uniformity of the plan so I buy
the most expensive primitive range I one
under then kind of if I need 200 pen I
will buy 250 print under then for some
research for the length of the first Lib
I even make them all the same the number
of the
the size of the festive ebin all the
same so they are very very beautiful or
prime material no kind of because they
are some micro right on a micro right
rather kind of they are important for
the termination and the termination of
the OTC and an early stage of the OTC
during commercially we can just use
fertilizer to have a good growth of the
Phalaenopsis so we don't need to do that
during the tissue culture stage I
believe so because kind of in a very
very beginning I assure you that we give
different rate of nitrogen are different
rate of phosphorous and different rate
of potassium kind of nippy behaviors
very very are similar so from my
research I demoed demonstrate is a kind
of large pool of stone nitrogen I
believe it's the same for other are
adamant so novel a response to the UH
Neutron deficit of deficiency who are
very very similar I mean this they also
have a kind of the storage of function
of potassium because with a very very
healthy plan you withheld the potassium
for one and a half year yes they will do
it good yes okay okay I would see that
is that we have heard of an herbaceous
plant that takes two years to do an
experiment on my line so it's not just
apple trees so Alex thank you very much
well thank you okay thank you thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu